this is a production of cornell
university
okay so one i want to thank all of the
the industry members who have been
sponsoring
our expo i i'd like to thank
uh gemma who's a backbone of of this
part of the symposium who is is keeping
us all together
uh and doing the work behind the scenes
uh i'd also like to thank all of uh
cornell cooperative extension personnel
who have worked very hard to pivot this
meeting from an in-person event to
a virtual
presentation and uh last but certainly
not least i'd like to thank dr terry
basilson who is my co-presenter for
today
he is an assistant professor at rutgers
university he is an excellent weed
scientist working in specialty crops and
he is a phenomenal collaborator uh not
only from extension outreach
opportunities such as this but also
research trials that we have together
and i am extremely lucky to have the
opportunity to be working with him
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
get on to our introduction to to
herbicides and this is going to be the
first talk that's going to be the
background
for the remaining of the topics
today uh and this specific uh
presentation obviously we're going to
have to talk about what the problems are
with weeds
this is our kind of obligatory slides of
why you should care about this material
we'll talk about herbicides and the
history of herbicide
herbicides and herbicide use we'll talk
about why herbicides don't work and then
we'll talk about herbicide sites of
action um specifically how we're going
to classify them for
the details that you're really here for
the sites of action
so again problems with weeds they are
direct competitors with crops that
result in yield loss and that's compa
competing for water light nutrients uh
but they also reduce harvest efficiency
they can actually stop men and machinery
from moving in the field
uh species like daughter or mistletoe or
broom rate can parasitize the crops
themselves
they can be the hosts for past or
pathogens of crops
they are dangerous or noxic poisonous
toxic hazardous in their own right think
poison ivy or giant hogweed and they
disrupt ecosystem services and
aesthetics so where i came from most
recently out in the western u.s medusa
had alters fire cycles and that has huge
implications
uh for many ecosystems in an entire
region of the u.s
now if we go back to yield losses which
tend to be very important what we think
about primarily
is weeds if they are not managed can
result in substantial yield losses
so this is work that has been done by
the weed science society of america the
yield loss committee if if we have best
management practices in place but we
don't manage our weeds
they estimated that in our major crops
we could see anywhere from 50 to 71
yield loss and that can account for
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
in economic losses up to billions of
dollars a year in economic losses
so we need to manage weeds and the
primary tool that we're using for
suppressing this unwanted vegetation
are herbicides
now herbicides have been the dominant
pesticide applied in our major agronomic
production environment so corn soybeans
cotton across time but that doesn't mean
that they aren't important
or or aren't significant or aren't
highly used in specialty crops as well
so the sla the figures on the left-hand
part of this slide uh that green bar
at the top of each figure for corn
soybeans and cotton that's herbicide use
and that's historical herbicide use
going back to the 50s and 60s and and
you can see how heavily we relied
on
uh these chemicals uh particularly in
our our soybean systems and in our corn
systems
but again like i said that doesn't mean
that we aren't using
um
herbicides extensively in our specialty
crops on the right hand side of the
slide these figures
are for some select specialty crops
apples blueberries peaches onions
pumpkins and snappings maybe we don't
have quite the same uh degree of
separation and the amount of herbicides
we use relative to insecticides or
fungicides but we're still applying
herbicides to significant acres uh
across the united states
so if we just want to think about
historical chemical weed control
we've been using herbicides for quite
some time to manage unwanted vegetation
now they might not look
quite the same uh as as the products
that we're used to using today so for
instance in the 1800s there's documented
use of lime for control of equisetum
species
in 1902 sodium arsenite for the control
of water hyacinth
one of my favorites uh 1915 the report
of the amount of salt that they were
using for the control of field bindweed
this was you know at the
you know three to five ton per acre
uh limit along uh rail roads uh to
suppress this vegetation uh but what
we're really kind of interested in what
we're gonna focus in is our synthetic
herbicides and the start of the chemical
era of agriculture these products uh
began in about 1942.
so this is a timeline of the release of
herbicide sites of
action uh all the way from the early
1900s to the most recent uh site of
action that was released the group 28
what i've done on this slide is i've
highlighted all the the different uh
wssa groups that you might be familiar
with so the eight you know the group
fours the group fives the group sixes so
four would be auxins
five and six are a photosystem two
inhibitors fourteen are our ppo
inhibitors the 27s are our hppd
inhibitors
now you can see is that there was an era
where we had a lot of herbicide
discovery and release uh between the the
50s and the 80s and and then we have
kind of a dry spell until 28 uh was
brought out and that was just brought
out so many of our herbicide classes are
what you might consider old
um
and the the big question is is when are
we going to get new ones uh everyone
wants to know when when is the new
herbicide mode of action coming out
and yeah i'm gonna tell you we shouldn't
necessarily be
uh relying on this again you know this
kind of exponential growth of novel
herbicide mode of action released uh the
group 28
just came out fmc announced this there's
there's a new herbicide active
ingredient it's part of a new class of
herbicides
uh but don't get too excited it's
primarily for use in rice production
systems which aren't dominant here in
new york
and then the next announcement that i
have seen that even suggesting about our
novel
you know herbicide motivation site of
action uh is from bear and saying that
they anticipate it coming out in 2030.
so this is going to kind of be the
hallmark of some of the stuff that that
terry and i are going to say
you know
at the base of of what we want you to
why we want you to understand our
herbicides is we need to preserve these
chemistries
over the long term because we aren't
going to be getting
new technologies
now what are some of the constraints in
place that might be preventing the
release of new herbicide sites of action
or new herbicide active ingredients
part of this is the cost of discovery
and commercialization
uh part of it is the just it's the
biological constraint it's the
availability of target sites within
plant cells uh that herbicides can go
after so to speak
and then there's the consolidation of
chemical companies
uh which may influence um
herbicide discovery
so in case you're wondering about the
cost of new herbicide release
this is from steve duke's paper in 2008
uh he estimated that it cost
246 million dollars to bring a new
synthetic pesticide to market
and there are additional costs on top of
that for re-registration of products for
adding new active ingredients changing
use patterns
registrations in different states new
york may have additional regulatory
hurdles that chemical companies need to
address which can cost
uh money uh to be able to bring a new uh
pesticide to market here in the state
specifically
and then there's the biological
constraint how many target sites are
there within plant cells that herbicides
can go after so
understand that herbicides
bind to specific sites within the cell
and these these these target sites have
to be critical for plant survival so
you've got to find a site that you can't
have an alternate pathway around it's
got to be
a lethal
inhibition
you don't want to have a comparable
target site in a non-target organism
particularly as mammals for for safety
reasons
and then a target site you don't want it
in great abundance because you want to
be able to easily inhibit this target
site with low use rates
with respect to chemical company
consolidation and the impacts on
competition and commercialization i've
seen it argued both ways
so it suggests that the
the
um
the evolution of our our chemical
companies and their consolidation
leads to less competition now we're
talking about you know these these
bigger
these bigger companies involved in uh
discovery and development that's not to
say that there aren't a lot of smaller
companies out there that are engaged in
this process because there are but you
know we tend to think about the the
bears the chem china the fmc the cortez
the basf
so
are these consolidations uh resulting in
less competition
but there are other people who are
arguing because these companies are also
consolidating uh their their seat
company profiles that this could
actually facilitate innovation because
it may
encourage them to maximize
trait technology uh and and therefore to
to invest investigate uh new pesticides
we're gonna talk about herbicides we
obviously want to talk about herbicide
failure
uh and herbicides are not always
effective we we use them
uh but they're not going to be a hundred
percent
um
effective and there's a lot of reasons
why we can see herbicide failures
sometimes it's we pick the wrong
herbicide
um
to go against a target weed or we don't
use it at the right rate or spray volume
we're not using the suggested recommend
or recommended additives such as
adjuvants
we may have antagonism we may mix two
products and the the use of both of them
at the same time
may reduce the efficacy of one or other
or there could be spray solution issues
uh such as water being too acidic or not
acidic enough that can affect the
performance of these chemicals
the weeds might just be too tall at the
time of application and we don't get
complete coverage or they might be
stressed
uh stressed weeds particularly with our
systemic herbicides don't respond well
to the chemistries that we're applying
there could be herbicide or
environmental factors affecting either
the deposition or the activation of
these products and then there's
herbicide resistance
and herbicide resistance is an
evolutionary process where we
we have a species a population where we
have this transition from uh susceptible
to resistant due to genetic changes that
are already present in the population
that limit the efficacy of the herbicide
and what happens is that our repeated
use of certain chemistries over time and
space removes all of the susceptible
plants and leaves the resistant ones
present and they just continue to
reproduce survive and thrive
uh in these systems where the selection
pressure is in their favor
you can think of it this way we used to
be able to kill this weed with this
herbicide at this rate and now we can't
okay
but i'm going to let you know the
situation is is pretty significant
right now worldwide we have 509 unique
cases of herbicide resistance
we have herbicide resistance that's been
found in 266
species around the world to 164
different herbicides
and the united states
leads the way with 123
cases
now
weeds can be resistant to more than a
single herbicide at a time uh it's not
that uh there's a lot of populations out
there that are resistant to just roundup
or maybe just first-rate herbicide or
this herbicide or that herbicide but
there are populations out there that are
resistant to multiple herbicides at the
same time meaning that using both of
these herbicides
you can't control it with one and you
can't control it with the other
sometimes the resistance there's one
mechanism that's controlling the
resistance
uh for for different uh herbicides and
sometimes we have multiple mechanisms
and we differentiate those from cross
resistance
and and multiple resistance and with
multiple resistance meaning more than
one mechanism that enables plants to
survive treatment with herbicides that
differ with respect to their sites of
action
and i'm going to use this figure this is
some herbicide resistant screening we've
been doing in new york and horseweed so
higher bars mean more dead plants
so population 7
100 percent death from both weather max
and first rate herbicide so this
population is susceptible to both of
these herbicides
population nine
we have a hundred percent death when we
used roundup weather max
however
we have very little death in this
population when we use first rate
herbicide so it's resistant to one
uh herbicide one side of action because
weather max and first rate have
different sites of action
population 17 we didn't control it with
roundup we didn't control it with first
rate so it is resistant
to both
of those chemistries
now this is actually a significant
concern when we're talking about
populations with resistance to multiple
sites of action to multiple chemistries
because as we start to accumulate these
multiple resistances
in our weed populations
it reduces the size of our
chemical toolbox that we have available
for management this is some data that dr
ian heap has been collecting it can be
found at the international survey of
herbicide resistantweeds
weedscience.org i definitely uh suggest
everybody go have a look at this site
it's quite eye-opening to look
uh at our our herbicide resistant issues
here in the united states and around the
world
of those
509 uh you know cases um
he's found and and identified 60
populations that have resistance to two
sites of action
there's 21 populations
out there weed populations out there
that are resistant to three
sites of action so three different
herbicides
active ingredients
13 are resistant to four five are
resistant to six and we have one that's
resistant or six are resistant to five
and we have one that's resistant to six
uh and and i'm if i'm correct and i i'd
have to look it up i think there's a rye
grass population in australia that might
be resistant to seven or more
herbicide sites of action so
it's a significant problem and again if
we start accumulating resistances
multiple resistances in a single
population we start reducing the
efficacy
of the products that
are available to us for managing
unwanted vegetation
so if you're curious about whether you
have resistance or not in weeds that
you're not a well able to control
there are some questions that you can
ask yourself
first and foremost is asking if you've
done everything right
were you using the correct rate were you
using the right herbicide um for
instance uh stinger chlopyralid you know
it it's effective against a very limited
uh number of species it's good against
the aster family and the legume family
but it's not going to provide control of
other broad leaf plant families so if
you're going after a weed that isn't in
those two target groups uh you might not
see effective control it's not
resistance it's just that product never
was going to work well in the first
place so are you doing everything right
are you doing everything according to
the label recommendations and are you
applying it at the correct time
are you using it against weeds that are
at their most sensitive stage and let's
face it that's going to be small and
succulent and not stressed
were there any environmental conditions
that could have affected your herbicide
performance
did you put out a post-emergence
herbicide and then get rained
immediately after that could have washed
the product off the leaves
or did you put out a residual soil
applied herbicide and then you didn't
get a rainfall event that was needed to
incorporate that herbicide into the soil
solution
are there patterns in your field that
could
suggest maybe something went wrong with
your spray uh program uh so for instance
when i was i was out in california i got
called out for
i think we've got an issue with
resistance
uh and every eighth row had weeds
that's not herbicide resistance that's a
clogged nozzle okay so that's that's a
that's a pattern suggestive of something
else that's not related to a genetic
evolutionary change leading to
resistance
but if you have live plants that are
intermixed with dead plants of the same
species
or other susceptible species and all
these plants were at the same size when
you treated them so if you treated at a
two-leaf stage a four-leaf stage
according to the label recommendations
and everything was done right and you
killed some
but not others then we should start to
be concerned that we're looking at a
case of herbicide resistance
or if you have a problem that's getting
worse over years you have a patch that
seems to be growing
uh or a weed that seems to be expanding
uh on in your fields when you're using
um
a same herbicide or same class of
herbicide over time then we want to be
concerned
and or if you know that you have cases
of herbicide resistance nearby you know
maybe for instance with horse wheat and
horse weed has seed that can be
dispersed on wind currents and you know
a neighbor has a problem with this and
now you have a problem with this
then we should be thinking about whether
you have herbicide resistance
and if you do have herbicide resistance
or you suspect you can reach out to your
cce personnel
you can reach out to me
and we can collect seed and we can do uh
screening
because we definitely need to know if we
have novel cases of resistance
developing in our state
so
if you do suspect that you have
herbicide resistance or if we want to
mitigate or prevent the development of
herbicide resistance the best thing you
can do is understand the biology of the
weeds that you're going to be dealing
with in your field
the better that you understand the
biology the more
able you are to build a diversified
integrated and dynamic program
to suppress those unwanted individuals
make sure you're starving clean and you
are staying clean as possible so
planting weed-free seed
maintaining your field as clean as
possible and preventing field to field
spread
that includes managing field edges again
first instance something like horse weed
it's dispersed by a wind currents and
letting it go
in one site can facilitate problems
developing in a remote site
managing weeds at harvest and post
harvest to prevent the the buildup of
your seed bank
using multiple herbicide modes of action
at labeled rates
again
recommended weed sites and diversifying
your chemical strategies both within and
between seasons so we're not in keeping
enhancing or increasing
a selection pressure for one specific
product
scouting your fields regularly to
identify any escapes early
and you know understanding that we don't
have to rely solely on uh chemistries
for managing unwanted vegetation so
adopting cultural and physical
strategies
as you can to manage weeds
in your fields on your field edges
so now we're going to uh this is just
our introduction to our our next top
which talk which is going to start
looking at the herbicide sites of action
is when we're talking about herbicides
there's a lot of different ways that we
can describe or that we can classify
them
you know and we use a lot of these words
uh when when people when terry and i
give these talks we we throw out this
terminology and then sometimes we we we
combine this terminology together there
these these these classifications are
are not independent or exclusive
so we can talk about controlling weeds
about the spectrum of control whether we
have broad spectrum we get a lot of
species or very narrow so
selective versus non-selective um the
movement within the plant we're going to
talk about herbicides that are contact
products so they burn the tissue they
can that they come into contact with and
therefore you need good coverage or
we're going to talk about products that
are systemic and translocated in the
plant so they're applied and then they
are moved within the plant to where
their target site is
we talk about timing we'll use timing
relative to weeds so prior to their
emergence or post-emergence but we also
talk about timing relative to the crop
so pre-plant in crop or post-harvest
then we talk about modes of action and
sites of action and that's what's going
to focus here today
and i'm going to tell you that this
isn't always easy to understand because
sometimes we use these terms
interchangeably and i'll show you an
example of this next
so mode of action is defined as kind of
like a big overall picture the general
way in which a herbicide controls
susceptible plants
whereas the site of action is talking
about the very specific biochemical site
and process that's disrupted again
sometimes mode of action and site of
action
are used interchangeably and i'm gonna
sorry i'm gonna use this as an example
so the the left part of this slide is a
screen capture i got from the university
of wisconsin
they they break up one of their
handbooks modes of action amino acid
synthesis
inhibitors and then they talk about the
specific site of action the wssa group
two is being the als inhibitors the als
inhibiting herbicides
whereas the hrac uh website if you look
at the right side talks about that exact
same group two the als inhibitors and
calls it the mode of action so
understand that different groups may
have different words uh for describing
the same thing but terry and i will talk
to you what we mean by the site of
action which is going to be
the specific biochemical pathway
so for instance this is just an example
bramoxinil
it's a the mode of action it's a
photosynthesis two inhibitor it
generates reactive oxygen species its
site of action is specifically it binds
to the d1 protein at histidine 215. okay
that's a difference between mode of
action and site of action general versus
specific
so this is how we're going to break up
today's talks uh
teary this is the atriac mode of action
classification
uh poster you can get this at
hrack.com
i think it does a nice job about
grouping herbicides into those
herbicides that generate light reactive
light activation of reactive oxygen
species
and then those herbicides that affect
cellular metabolism and those herbicides
that affect cell division and growth
um down here in this red box uh this is
going to be our sites of action this is
what terry and i are going to focus on
um but specifically we're going to break
it up where teary's going to talk about
the reactive oxygen species generating
herbicides that's going to be our next
half hour then i'm going to talk about
the herbicides that disrupt cell
metabolism division and growth and then
teary's going to come back and talk
about keeping those products on site on
target uh and preventing environmental
concerns uh and and injury uh to our
crops and off target organisms
so again we're going to break it up this
way
terry's going to do roses i'm going to
do uh the other two categories just so
you can see what's coming the reactive
oxygen species those burners those are
products like basa grand callisto and
gold tender rely and command
the cell metabolism division and growth
inhibitors products like 2 24d dicamba
and allion matrix roundup
so thank you very much i'm going to stop
sharing my screen and i am going to pass
it off
uh to teary and he can take our next
topic
thanks lee and i uh i will start sharing
my screen
hopefully it will work
nicely
can you can you can you see my screen
yes you can
see your screen but you might need to
take it into presentation mode
here we go
excellent
okay
all right so well thank you lynne for
inviting me today to the
uh to the new york expo for presenting
together on herbicide and to give this
lecture on
the 101 basically of herbicide the basis
of our wheat science um thank you steve
also for inviting me today on uh
well yes i agreed in uh when uh when
we're working together we we're really i
think a great team of wheat scientists
and we are doing a lot of research
together so it's it's really something
that i enjoy doing a lot
um
but my talk today was really you know i
mean it's really
following what lynn explained regarding
heavy side uh site of action on we'll be
really focusing right now uh on the
photosynthesis inhibitors
um before i start really i mean if if
you have questions don't hesitate to put
them in in the chat box uh sorry for the
friendship sound but it's already too
late for me to change it so i will keep
it
but if you have any questions please do
not hesitate to put that in the chat box
um lynn explained it but
really it's really important to
understand the difference between a mode
of action on the side of action so
eventually because they're very
used in touch interchangeably by with
scientists and it should not be the
right way to do it we should be a little
bit more precise when we're using this
term so mode of action it's really the
biome biochemical mechanism by which an
herbicide
will cause growth to cease in a targeted
plant uh if you're looking at the site
of action that's the exact location
that's exactly where the herbicide is
acting in the plant it can be an enzyme
it can be a different type of molecule
in the plant but that's where the
herbicide is really acting the mode of
action is the consequence of you know of
this binding to something in the plant
so for example if you're looking um at
the
aloe sulfuron herbicide sandia
this one sander will inhibit acetylate
synthesis which is an enzyme in the
plant which is involved in the synthesis
of branched uh chain amino acids so by
binding to this enzyme aldosterone will
shut down the production of branch
chain amino acid in the plant and that's
what what will cause the plant to die
because these amino acids are essential
for plant growth if the plant is not
able to produce them anymore the plant
will will directly quickly
um
so herbicides are classified by site of
actions that's that's the way we are
classifying this day
um so the classification code is
required on the label uh so for most of
the products that we you will find in
the us you will have the code or really
on the first page on the label i'll give
you an example grammar sun park what you
look uh on the top right corner you see
group 22 herbicide that's indicative of
what kind of site of action this episode
is targeting um so that's that's
targeting the photosystem one uh of the
plan so that's that's uh
that's an episode that we'll be
discussing a little bit later in the
presentation today uh lynn discuss
services resistance on really what we're
doing today it's important with regard
to
herbicide resistance management
most importantly one of the very
important recommendations for delaying
or preventing the onset of herbicide
resistance
is really to rotate herbicide site of
action and eventually use a mixture of
different herbicide site of action for
preventing the selection of a specific
weak biotype that may be resistant to a
specific herbicide so knowing these
numbers is really important because that
will help you to effectively rotate your
site of action when you are playing some
herbicides
um so lean presentation is this poster
which is really classifying all the
herbicides that are available on the
market these days i will really focus on
on on the photosynthesis uh herbicides
the one that are targeting the
photosynthesis just to give you an
example
on this slide you you look at the at the
green box on on the top left
these heavy side are known to inhibit
photosystem ii
which is there's two different type of
photosystem in the plant where the
photosynthesis is taking place there's
photosystem one photosystem two we have
so many sites that are targeting
photosystem two actually you have two
numbers you have number five and you
have number six why because you have the
same mode of action but you have two
different site of action you have
herbicide that will target a specific
protein on some herbicide that will be
binding to other another location on
this protein so they will be classified
in two different sites of sites of
action so looking at photosynthesis
that's really you know that's really the
basic um
of the plant on without photosynthesis
there would be no problems uh on that we
have a
variety of herbicides that are really
targeting photosynthesis so just as a
reminder uh photosynthesis is when the
plants are taking up taking up carbon
dioxide from the air to produce sugars
via photosynthesis
as a result of this photosynthesis
process oxygen is produced as a product
of photosynthesis on the plant will also
produce glucose as that will be sugar
that will be used in other
process you know um in the plant on the
plant really needs the light energies
the plants are pretty much only one um
in you know in the living world to to
use light energy for for really
realizing this photosynthesis process
um to look a little bit more into the
detail and it's important to understand
what's going on right here because
that's where some of the photosynthesis
herbicide will be targeting so basically
the plant is absorbed by absorbing
photon absorbing light on that will
generate a chain of electron transport
so basically the plant is absorbing the
photons energy from the sun it's
breaking down a water molecule that will
generate electrons that will be
transported
through different molecules on in the
process of transport that will generate
energy for the plant so the plant is not
using directly electron for making other
process but the electrons that are
transported are helping to the
generation of energy in the form of atp
adenosine triphosphate or nadph on these
molecule of energy if you want will be
used by the plant for for making other
products for making amino acids for
making sugars or making lipids or for
generating everything that the plant
needs but really the basic is right here
it's a production of energy that the
plant will need later for
other chemical processes
on herbicide we'll be targeting some
molecules that are really
important in this uh
photosynthesis process
so the first group is released of dubai
wssa group 5 and group 6
6 this one are inhibiting photosynthesis
at photosystem 2 and actually if you
look at your remember what i presented
in the previous slide these herbicide
are binding uh to the d1 protein protein
uh uh
you know during the electron chain
transport and by binding to this protein
they are blocking the transport of
electron in the photosystem
um on by doing that i mean if the plant
is still collecting energy from the sun
but if you don't have transport of
electron uh
within the cell that will generate a lot
of idea active molecules that we are
calling reactive oxygen species
on these molecules will be
reacting with pretty much uh everything
which is forming the plant so especially
lipids
lipids and proteins that are really
important for the membrane of the cell
of the plant cells will be attacked by
reactive oxygen species and will be and
will be degraded really quickly
you have different group of herbicide in
this photosystem two inhibitors you have
the triazine
such as atrazine and cimazine you have
the treyasin none which is a different
uh chemical family with metroposition
you have ureas diorama and niron two
herbicides very important for for veggie
production on in the natural family we
have bentenzo bentazon sorry which is
also a photosystem to inventor
um so these are bicycles intraesinone
ureas are very often most often soil
applied are eventually early post
emergence uh so relatively quickly after
the wheat start emerging but you don't
want to wait uh the wheat to be too tall
uh to apply these emergence this uh this
herbicide uh but they are really mostly
considered as residual herbicide
they're absorbed by both the shoots from
the roots uh and they are only
translocated in the zealand of the
plants so really the seedling is where
where the water is moving in the plant
so that's where these herbicides are
moving into the plant
uh the nitrile bentazon are early
post-emergence herbicide uh they're
mostly contact at this side because they
are not translocated in the plant they
are not moving from the roots uh to the
shoots
they are really uh acting where they've
been sprayed where they've been eating
the plants
um some soil applied a photosystem to
heavy sites such as atrazine or cimazine
can carry over to following uh to
following sensitive crop and i took a
picture when i i borrowed a picture to
uh dr alan new york at nc state uh
showing some uh symptoms of
ultrasound carryover on tobacco and
that's what we'll be discussing in the
next few slides we'll be discussing what
is the symptomology uh that that is
characteristic of this photosystem to uh
inhibitor herbicides
so really i mean this photosystem to
inhibitor release what is really um
outstanding with them what you will see
very frequently is really leaf chlorosis
so a yellow wing of the leaf lift and
impale and after a while it will start
uh generating necrosis as well um so you
will have a lot of interventional
process so the main veins of the leaf
will stay green but everything between
the veins can start to turn yellow
you will have some marginal necrosis or
curling on the margin of the leaf and
what is really typical with this
photosystem to inhibitor when you're
looking at injury
the oldest leaves are always the one
showing symptom first and if in my
previous slide on tobacco you could see
that the basal leaf of the plant the two
first leaf of the plant was the one
showing symptoms actually the new shoots
were still looking uh good looking green
but really the oldest leaf are assuring
the
first one to show symptoms
you can see that again on this picture
this one is a picture on of of treason
injury uh
polyatrazine
on clicker bits and on again i mean it's
a nice picture to really visualize how
these herbicides are causing damage you
see a lot of
yellowing on necrosis later on between
the veins of the leaf the veins are
still green and if you're looking at the
picture on the left
you see that the new shoots are in the
newest lid the smaller sleeve in the
center of the plant are green but the
oldest leaf have been the one
showing showing injury from from
photosystem to inhibitor herbicide
a few other
slides showing some uh some symptomology
but this time with metropoisin again the
other leaves will show interval on
marginal process
followed by dieback
you have some curling on the margin of
the leaf
um
in some situation you can look at the
great picture the great picture on the
bottom right you may have some more
cloud of internal process that we
developed after necrotic tissues have
dropped
um if is a young if especially in in
bushes
such as blueberry
if you if you apply these herbicide on
on new blueberry chain that have not
been hardening that are still green that
don't have a solid bark you may have
necrosis of young tender stem exposed to
the spray on on this one and with this
herbicide you will not see root injury
lynn will discuss some other type of
episode that will be causing a root
injury with this type of herbicide when
you have damage
it's it's really affecting the foliage
of the plant not much uh the roots of
the plant
this one is serbacy it's very specific
besides that we were using in in
blueberry which i'm familiar with
because i'm working a lot with blueberry
we are really careful not using it a lot
because it's it's really a
dangerous service if you want
potentially causing injury in sandy soil
but again you will see the same kind of
pattern with pale green to yellow leaves
turning brown on dying
you may have grown or red red spots uh
again marginal and internal products
this is typical of terabyte injury as
well i mentioned blueberries but yes
definitely here in new jersey
we were growing blueberries in some of
the soil on in this type of soil where
you're really a
you know it's a very permeable soil you
in some situation you don't have always
a lot of organic matter so you don't
have any buffering capacity of the soil
if you want on we know that turbo seal
can be extremely injurious to blueberry
uh in in some situation uh in depending
on the type of salt
um another type of
herbicide affecting the photosystem
is glutamine synthetase and it's it's
really is only pretty much one episode
in this group uh
that is widely used it's glyphosate rely
uh so this herbicide is really targeting
uh the glutamine synthetase uh enzyme
activity and that's the enzyme that will
convert glutamate to ammonia onto
glutamine
on that something which is really
important for for amino acid production
in the plant
when when actually when you're blocking
this enzyme what will happen is that you
will have a lot of ammonia accumulation
in the plant on this ammonia will
destroy the cells on directly inhibit
photosystem 1 on photosystem 2 reaction
in addition um
the high ammonia because it
will change the ph
of the cells the ph gradient across the
membrane and by doing that you will
prevent
basically the production of energy by
the plant because you need to get some
dragon ph between inside the cell and
outside of the cell um if you don't have
this gradient you don't have this
exchange for for the cell you don't have
this energy production
on that will uh that will prevent the
pump to grow on on to develop
um so some some characteristic of
glyphosate it's do not confuse
glyphosate with glyphosate okay we are
really talking about a different
herbicide than glyphosate uh glyphosate
is not a photosystem uh in editorial
decide if you want
so glyphosate it's quickly absorbed to
soil it's very rapidly degraded it has
absolutely no soil activity
uh it's strictly a post-imaging service
size so you need to apply it on emerge
weeds
um it does limited transformation
meaning that it will not just stay where
you apply it on the leaf it may move a
little bit around but it will not move
uh through the xlm or to the flame of
the plant it has some really limited
transformation on most of the case it
will act much like a contact herbicide
like park rats
it's a good heavy site for controlling
uh many annual broadleaf
weeds
um it's a decent herbicide for animal
grasses when they are uh relatively
small at the you know on small ceilings
exception is goose grass a goose grass
is not really
well controlled by by glucose in it
anything outside of of this type of
wheat anything such as nutsedge uh
perennial broadleaf wheats are bermuda
grass which is a perennial grass will
not be efficiently controlled by
glutathione so that's that's a
limitation of this herbicide
what what is the symptomology of uh
bufossinate uh so it's really killed at
the site of droplets you have slight
transformation but not to the entire
plant something completely different
from what you would expect from
glyphosate
so you will start to get some initial
burning within a few hours after
exposure
so it's it's starting to show symptoms
relatively quickly if you are comparing
that to what we just discussed before
the photosystem 2 inhibitors such as
atrazine metrobusiness herbicide it will
take days before you start
starting to see some some injury with
glyphosate yes within a couple of hours
you can start to see some some physical
effect on the plant
so after this initial burning basically
after i would say that most of the time
after a week the plant will really die
after a week
so injury symptoms include leaf burning
leaf distortion leaf pranking and
necrosis
it's it's relatively quick you know
compared to if you were to compare to
glyphosate that lin will discuss later
glyphosate is killing the weed more
rapidly than life is it
a few things that are really important
to keep in mind with glyphosate if you
if you use like
with glyphosate sorry if you use
glyphosate
uh the rate of injury or the efficacy of
the herbicide will be increased on the
bright sunlight condition usually i
recommend the growers to start using
bloophosinate rely
i would say between 10 am on
5 pm
we have done experimentation when i was
at nc state looking at applying
glucosinate very early in the morning
and it's really contrasting it's i mean
if you really applied it when when there
is no light
you will drastically reduce
the efficacy of the herbicide for
controlling weeds
it's also a good idea to apply
glucosinolate under high humidity
condition
and you have a good plant salt plant on
soil water balance again that's the idea
that this heavy side need to be applied
when the weeds are under good growth
condition
if the weeds are stressed by drought or
by temperature these weeds may not
absorb the herbicide on on the herbicide
will not be as efficient for controlling
some some some of these plants some of
these weeds um so there is crops that
have been um
genetically engineered for for getting
resistant through to glucosiness by
introducing uh in
you know putting the part or the bar
genes to this plant so basically what
these genes are doing to to into the
plant is that they will detoxify
glyphosate by attaching
uh an acetyl group if you want to the
glyphosate molecule and by doing that
it's it makes the glyphosate completely
inactive so it's not toxic anymore to
the plant so right now i mean there is
only three crops that have that have
been developed from in resistance to
glucosinate we have corn soybean on
cotton
um yeah i mean i show a picture as well
of some injury of glucose in it in a
nice booze in eye brush blueberry on
that's really new canes new shoot at the
base of the plant and you can already
see after seven days you can really see
the the necrosis that uh before it maybe
goes into these new shoots
um so
again a few pictures so you can see that
on on blueberry it can be tricky on
blueberry because you can cause a
necrosis of the growing pump on these
new canes so they are relatively small
if you don't have a shield for
protecting a
nuclear and some herbicide spray when
you are playing with fuzziness you may
get this kind of injury and if you're
hitting the tip of these new canes
basically the new canes will not keep
growing on on that's really a problem
because in blueberry we are regenerating
the plant by producing nutrients if you
don't have any nutrients as that will be
that will be an issue um you have some
uh drift injury from glufozinate uh
applied between rose on summer squash
and cantaloupe uh on the left picture
the plant did not recover on the right
picture maybe because it was a little
bit iron plastic we got drift we got
some leaf
severely damaged but the plant managed
to to keep growing
that may still affect you know the
ultimate the potential heat of the plant
later on
the ppo inhibitor so this one
uh group uh group number fourteen group
duplicate group number fourteen uh this
one are targeting the protocol felony
oxidase enzyme which is very uh very
important enzymes that help producing a
molecule which is a
precursor molecule for chlorophyll on in
which is
a chlorophyll is really needed for
photosynthesis for harvesting solar
energy the aim is needed for uh electron
transfer and i show you why electron
transfer were important in
photosynthesis so this is herbicide by
by targeting an enzyme which is really
important in this process uh we will
really
um you know cause injury i mean prevent
the plan to to to uh to uh to do
photosynthesis uh so in this scenario in
this case uh when you are inhibiting the
ppo uh enzyme uh that will also uh cause
production of reactive oxygen species
that again will attack on detroit and
destroy lipids on protein membranes
uh so that includes some herbicides that
are frequently used in specialty crops
you may be familiar with sulfantrazone
caffentrazone oxyclothin for mesophane
flumixazine all of them are ppo
inhibitor herbicides
so for most of them they really have
limited transformations they will behave
as as compact herbicide
they are typically applied pre-emergents
for most of them
there is one uh caffeine treason which
is a post-emergence because he has only
fourier activity so we are only using it
as a postman john's herbicide
so one of the big concern is specialty
crop which is heavy side is that the
soil persistence so there are residual
herbicide applied to the soil the
surplus systems will vary
depending on on crop species
so with some of them depending on the
rate depending on the soil depending on
the kind of crop that you're planting
the next year there is there is a risk
of terrible with some people besides
um fermented fanfare excising and oxy
fluorescent have both soil on foliar
activity caffeinated i mentioned it it's
strictly a foliar herbicide strictly
applied on emerge wheat
they are primarily used for controlling
bodily weeds but it's worth noting that
sulfantrazone
can also be applied for providing uh
search control we don't have many heavy
sites that are controlling sedges on
surfantra zone is one of them that can
provide some decent activity on sages
i was mentioning before the risk of
carryover on i just
i just extract this slide from from a
for mesa fan
label on look at some you know for for
for some of the crop you have to wait up
to uh 12 months and if it's not if the
props are not listed right here you have
to wait up to 18 months before planting
back some of these crops so the risk of
carry-over with this pto herbicide
it's not something you know to take
lightly you really have to read the
label to to make sure that you will not
put yourself in a situation where okay i
i applied there besides this year but
if i plan to plan this problem next year
make sure that you read the label for
for for making sure that you will not be
in the situation where you can have
potential carry about injuries
uh another group of uh well i mean see
some some people are beside injury
most of the time i mean the injury will
look like water soap spot on the leaf as
this spot will turn brown and just after
within a few days a complete plant the
entire plant will die
and it's really killing only at the site
of droplets
and i will show you that on the next
slide
that's a slide of um of blueberry damage
uh that i i upset a few uh years ago in
new jersey and actually it's not drift
damage it's not coming from
spring the herbicide actually the
herbicide was applied
on the ground as a result herbicide
premier jones but i told you before we
have some decide in new jersey on the
grower came a few days later to apply a
fertilizer
drove the tractor it was extremely dry
soil it created a lot of dust the dust
went into the atmosphere went back onto
the leaves and created all these
injuries because basically the herbicide
was attached to this particle
went back onto the leaves on you just
have to get due in the morning that will
allow the herbicide to get back in
solution okay on to be absorbed by the
plant and to create this damage so this
kind of uh what we're calling shotgun
effect of ppo episode that's typical of
ppo herbicide injury either as physical
drift but also has dust drift in in that
case
inhibition of photosynthesis at ps1 so
it's a different area so before we are
looking at photosystem two now we are
looking at photosystem one on this one
are really the extrude side apparent
part on diquat so this one will inhibit
photosynthesis by competing for electron
transfer in photosystem one
so basically when when the herbicide is
reduced by an electron so it will
scavenge electron uh during the the
photo synthesis
this herbicide will rapidly transfer the
electron to oxygen forming a highly
reactive superoxide so these reactive
oxygen species and again you will start
the process of of degrading damaging uh
the cell membrane of
the plant
so this one are post-emergence contact
uh foliar applied herbicide they are
really good on broadleaf species not so
much on grasses they have no
transportation they have no residual
activity actually when you are playing
paraquat it's uh it's relatively rapidly
uh
inhibited in the soil because it will
bind to soil particle relatively quickly
so it will have absolutely no uh
residual activity
um some some symptoms so the symptoms
with these herbicides are showing up
very quickly within within two hours if
you have the right condition uh you you
will see these symptoms so ps1 inhibitor
will be
the activity will be increased when you
under bright sunlight when you have high
humidity when you have a moist soil this
condition again will enhance exactly
this herbicide so the symptoms are
typical uh you you will have leaf water
soaking within hours of treatment
followed by necrosis within four to six
hours um
on
spotting i mean we i mean i i put a
picture right here but it's again on
blueberry that was sparkling drift uh
you may you be used to
here about 240 or die combat drift but
any kind of herbicide can physically
drift on actually in that situation that
was quite drift injury on iboost
blueberry at the time of blooming on
actually uh the growers i mean some of
these flowers were killed by paraquat
and we didn't get production on this
field so something we need to to to be
to be careful with
uh some some typical injury again i mean
mostly necrosis uh really relatively
quickly you don't see the clauses that
you will see with some other herbicide
it will be mostly necrosis um on
in that situation on the right side uh
that was daiquiri that was spread on
strawberry leaf and actually because the
deep vein on this leaf will act as a
drain
basically it's the the the
the veins drain the herbicide that was
uh that drifted on this leaf and
accumulated the herbicide at the bottom
of the leaves that's why you have higher
injury already at the basis of the leaf
the last group that we'll be discussing
today the pigment inhibitors a bleacher
um you you see why we're calling them
richer because they're turning really uh
weeds completely white
so this one are carotenoid biosynthesis
inhibiting herbicide
basically what they do is that they are
interfering with the production of
carotenoids and carotenoids are
extremely important because they are the
molecule in the plant that will protect
chlorophyll from from photo oxidation so
if there is too much energy the
clarifier molecule is relatively samsy
sensitive the keratinoids will be there
to protect
chlorophyll and scavenge any excess of
solar energy that made with japan so we
have different group because they are
acting a different side 12 13 and 27
this type of herbicide will be really
controlling many annual broadleaf
species on some
chromosome
grasses
north rezone are
only applied to the soil a mesotriune
which is uh in group 27
can be applied to the soil on also post
emergence to the foliage of the plant
so the symptoms are very evident that's
probably the easiest symptoms to uh to
decipher when you when you have some
herbicide injury so it's really uh the
leaves are completely turning white
because you don't have
protection of the of the chlorophyll so
chlorophyll is really degraded extremely
quickly by by by light um so the effect
um the effect
on the plant is that if you have
chromosomes all tissues are usually
affected first uh if you have vapor
drift it may be generally that the newer
leaves will be affected first
mesotrion is more systemic on you can
have
symptoms on both old on new leaves
some uh some picture of herbicide hppd a
beside a clomazon carryover on vegetable
crops so you will see a lot of green in
some situation it can be relatively
similar to what you will get from
photosystem 2 inhibitor by by showing a
lot of process
but you will really have this kind of
white flash uh um
not turning not just saying yellow but
turning white so that's typical of
of this hppd inhibitor every side this
one is some common injury or even vapor
drift some eggplant on tomato
again on on this kind of crops i mean
the newest leaves will be the one
showing the most injury with this type
of
drift
uh on the last one that i wanted to
mention too is that these heavyside for
some of them can be also effective on on
surge on cg
uh i had this picture coming from near
the station where we applied a
mesotrione on annual sedge and clearly
you can really see the sages turning
white
the picture on the right is my favorite
read it's called redwood that's
something that is a problem here in new
jersey in cranberry and that's that's
another type of mesotrione is a good
episode for controlling a mesotrion
again i mean that's really visual you
can see that only the new shoots are
turning white uh showing that the the
herbicide is moving into the plant
translocating moving to the new shoots
on on for them to turn white
with that said that was my last slide on
lim i think you have a few
few other type of episodes to discuss
today
great thank you thank you terry by the
way there is a question um if you could
just uh in the chat to reiterate the the
pigment inhibitors um just the the
numbers of the groups yes so the pigment
the pigment inhibitor is group 12 13 on
27.
so
i think 27 is mesotrion
north razon maybe group 12
group 139 chromosome is group 12 as well
but 12 13 on
27. all right so we're going to jump
into the the next group of products that
we're we're going to talk about uh terry
discuss uh the herbicides that are
associated with the generation of
reactive oxygen species which tend to
result in in burning of tissue
ultimately
i'm going to talk about these two
categories cellular metabolism
inhibitors and cell division and growth
inhibitors
specifically i'm going to talk about
these these categories the the the group
twos which are als inhibitors the group
ones 15
29 9 3 and 4. so we're not going to
cover all the classes because
a lot of these other classes
don't have a lot of herbicides in them
or aren't
used uh readily in in our production
environment
so we're going to go in numerical order
and we're going to start with a wssa
category one and this is the inhibition
of acetyl coa carboxylase
sorry
so um that that first group so
these are going to be herbicides uh in
the group one they are absorbed through
the foliage so foliar applied products
and they're translocated
uh to the growing points where they
inhibit meristematic activity
and they specifically
uh
cause damage to the plant by
uh
inhibiting the acc enzyme and the acc
enzyme catalyzes the first step in fatty
acid synthesis
and you're going to be like why is this
important and we're going to have this
why is this important why do i care
uh where we explain um how these
herbicides are acting and it's important
uh that that this herbicide acts the
weight is because fatty acids make up
the tails of lipids and lipids can plot
comprise plant cell membranes um so
they're comprising the organelle
membranes and the the greater cell
membrane at large so if you remember
back to your basic biology
on the left hand side of the slide this
is uh this is a lipid there's there's
the head and then there's the fatty acid
tail and then on the right hand side
this is the lipid uh bilayer your cell
membrane lipid bilayer and what happens
is is those yellow tails that's what the
acca herbicides um
prevent the development of and if we
can't make these lipids we can't develop
uh fully formed organelles uh and we
can't develop that plant cell membrane
and therefore it affects the ability of
the plants to to grow and develop if you
can't make these basic structures
the acca is inhibiting herbicides
there's 25 active ingredients um in this
group and these are going to be our fops
and our dims so seth oxidim fluoasapop
penoxidine
these are our grass herbicides and the
symptoms that they produce tend to be
yellowing
uh wilting sometimes you can see that
that reddening and the the purpling
associated with crop damage and because
we these these uh herbicides they move
to the meristematic tissue and they
affect plant growth plant expansion uh
plant development you can get uh
necrosis and dead heart uh occurring
where you have
uh the the death of these uh
meristematic tissues and basically as
you can see with this this corn plant
and just
pop that that that head right out
because that tissue uh
has died and is not able to develop
further
so
the second category is going to be the
wssa2 category and those are going to be
the herbicides that inhibit acetolactate
synthase
all right so they're going to be the
herbicides in the the blue box uh at the
top of this session section it's a very
big uh chemical group and has a lot of
important herbicides
that we use
so these herbicides they can be foliar
or soil applied and can be adsorbed
absorbed by both roots and foliage and
then are translocated
uh to their sites of action now i'm
going to tell you with the the als
inhibiting herbicides they
might not be equally effective
against the same species if they're used
pre-emergence versus post-emergence um
one interesting thing that we found when
i was uh working out in california
in our tomato our processing tomato
production systems
is that matrix rim sulfuron which is in
this group applied post-emergence didn't
do much for suppressing field
bindweed
however if we used it pre-emergence we
were actually able to see
some suppression of the perennial field
bindweed
vines as they were emerging from the
ground so you can have very different
weed species that are being controlled
whether you're using it pre-emergence or
post-emergence
these herbicides inhibit the production
of branched-chain amino acids so
specifically the amino acids leucine
isoleucine and bailey again why is this
important
amino acids are the building blocks of
proteins and proteins are structural
components of plants and they're also
the enzymes
that carry out the duties that are
encoded by the genes uh within the plant
nucleus
so
this is
uh if you remember again back to basic
biology proteins are chains of amino
acids uh strung together
the als inhibiting herbicides interfere
with the biosynthesis of these three
amino acids specifically so proteins
that rely on these amino acids in in the
in their code uh won't be formed
properly because you're not going to
have these components of the strand
so again
nucleus we have our genes
that leads to
the translation of the genetic material
into the protein building that amino
acid chain specifically the als
inhibitors interfere with these three
enzymes and
their ability uh our ability to build
proteins reliant on these enzymes
now this is a big chemical class it's
got 57 active ingredients and seven
chemical families
some of the components some of the
active ingredients you might be familiar
with are the active ingredients that are
part of pursuit and matrix and raptor
and sandia
so the symptomology of these herbicides
uh sometimes we see the undersides of
leaves purpling
sometimes we might just see
the the red or purple color uh in the
main vein and in in the side veins of
the leaves
uh reducing wilting associated with this
and necrosis implant death but also at
really really really low rates uh we can
see leaf distortions that sometimes
might be confused with the group four
uh herbicides the auxin so sometimes we
think that leaf strapping and leaf
deformations are um you know
characteristic of that category alone no
very low doses of als inhibiting
herbicides and and glyphosate as well
can sometimes mimic uh some of those
responses this is a picture of some leaf
distortions that you're starting to see
on
hemp but i've also seen it on um
tomatoes
out in california where we had a
non-registered als inhibitor herbicide
drift onto the tomatoes at very low
rates and cause um
you know very
usually unusual and unique uh leaf
shapes
the third category that we're going to
talk about is the wssa group three and
these are going to be herbicides that
interfere
uh with microtubule assembly
uh so this is the category in in the
blue box up under cell division and
growth very small
uh chemical group
but an important one and one year you're
probably all familiar with
so the microtubule inhibitors are are
soil applied and they're primarily for
the pre-emergence control of annual
grasses and some broadleaf species we we
do tend to think of these as grass
herbicides predominantly
they're absorbed by roots and shoots of
emerging seedlings but not readily
translocated within the plant and they
bind to tubulin proteins so proteins at
the growing end of microtubules
why is it important
microtubule expansion
um is inhibited but microtubules are
incredibly important because they are
the plants cytoskeleton they keep
organelles within the cells in place and
they also form the mitotic spindles that
are needed for cell division and if you
interfere with microtubules you are
going to interfere with cell division
and plant growth
so this is my crude uh you know figure
of of a microtubule what happens is is
that microtubules there are two proteins
the alpha and the beta tubulin they bind
together and then they bind to the
microtubule that is growing the
microtubule inhibitors interfere with
that growing step so you don't have
these microtubules that get bigger or
longer but you also start to have the
back end of the microtubules being
broken down so you're destroying the
cytoskeleton of the plant
here's a
better diagram of the plant cell you can
see where the red arrow is the the
cytoskeleton the microtubules you can
you can see there you know they're
they're kind of drawn visual uh
role as part of the cytoskeleton again
remember back to your
biology classes where we have the
mitotic spindles and we have our
chromosome separation
and associated with cell division and
that's how our plants get bigger by
having cells dividing and or interfering
with that process
and the ability to grow and organize
so
this is got 20 active ingredients three
chemical families um they include the
yellow herbicides uh treflan
pendimethalin arizolin ethylfluorulin um
you'll know these these are these can be
familiar and frequently used products
symptomology of the microtubule
inhibitors you can get stem swelling and
stubby roots again you get them taken up
uh by uh the roots and shoots of
emerging seedlings and then you have
that inhibition
of cell division and and and root
development so you get those stubby
roots you can see
uh some stunted growth and chlorosis you
can't see leaf puckering and other
deformations but really kind of
characteristic hallmark of this is the
stubby roots uh the swollen uh the
swollen um
the swollen stems uh last year we did a
study with hemp um and and we put down
uh some pendimethalin uh in some of our
our our trial sites to to look at uh
crop safety and then it rained a lot and
all of the stems were swollen and we
spent a good part of our summer is this
due to the rain or is this due to the
the panda methylene or is this a
combined effect
the group four herbicides are our
synthetic oxins
um
this is um
going to be our
chemistries that you're you're very
familiar with uh such as our 24d our
dicamba or chlopyrolid
these are products that are readily
absorbed through roots and foliage and
translocated to meristematic tissue okay
so they they don't just affect what they
contact uh they're moved within the
plant and they don't just disrupt a
single growth
process they disrupt multiple ones in
fact we don't even completely know
completely how the auxins are fully
working in plants because they can in
fact protein synthesis they can affect
nucleic acid metabolism they can
stimulate ethylene production which can
have its own impacts uh in the
development of
these plants
it's important because really what we
know them for is their impacts on cell
wall plasticity because they're
affecting the cell wall plasticity
that's what leads to a lot of the
distortions in the plant structures that
that further impact growth and
development that we're really
uh used to seeing so that's going to be
the twisting that's going to be the
cupping that's going to be the leaf
strapping
so again
this is a kind of a diagram of of of our
cell where two cell walls join together
and what we're seeing here is on the
left hand side of that little box that's
kind of popped out
is our our normal cell wall how its
components are rigid and interleaved
because those give
the plant its structure and its ability
to support itself and the auxins go in
and interfere with the uh the linkages
involved in in those cell wall
components and again that leads to the
bending and the twisting that we see
again it affects multiple sites auxins
affect multiple processes and multiple
sites within
uh our our plant cells but again
cellular
cellular processes that related to cell
wall development are really what we
characterize the injury as
so
dicamba 2 4d cloparolid stinger
quinclerac if you're familiar with
quinclorac which
acts as an oxen on broadleaf weed
species but maybe not on grasses it also
has control of grass as it does a
different mode of action
so again the symptomology uh associated
with our synthetic oxins there's the
epinasty and the twisting we see the
leaf cupping you know particularly with
dicamba injury that cupping is very
symptomatic of
dicamba contact on a plant we see leaf
strapping that's associated with several
auxins
group nine this is the inhibition and
i'm going to say this once a 5-enal
pyruval shakimate 3-phosphate synthase
we call it the eps ps inhibitors but you
can just refer to it as glyphosate
because it's the only chemical in this
family
so again the epsps inhibitors
um it's a foliar applied product and it
is systemic
and what it does is it interferes with
the shakimic acid pathway and this
pathway is also interferes with the
production of amino acids much like the
als inhibiting herbicides the group two
herbicides do
but this inhibits the aromatic amino
acids so specifically the amino acids
tyrosine tryptophan and phenylalanine
so why
is this important again
similar reason as we discussed before
amino acids are building blocks of
proteins proteins are important for the
structural
integrity of the cell they're also
components of enzymes that carry out
the activities that are encoded in plant
genes
so again
glyphosate is interfering with amino
acid production and the ability to form
these amino acid chains that are our
proteins it's phenylalanine it's
tyrosine and tryptophan the ringed amino
acids you can see the rings right there
uh in the chemical structures on the
screen
this is another picture
uh again showing where glyphosate works
uh in this entire shekimic pathway and
again tryptophan phenylalanine tyrosine
being affected
and we see that those amino acids those
protein chains aren't built
but then we also know that that these
amino acids do have roles in the
development of other plant structures
and other plant chemical compounds
phytolulexins lignins and indole acetic
acid iaa
again one active ingredient glyphosate
but there might be probably
hundreds if not thousands of formulated
products that have
this active ingredient this chemical in
it
the symptomology that we see
with
glyphosate uh we tend to see chlorosis
and usually the chlorosis starting at
the base of the leaf on the youngest
tissue because it's translocated to the
meristematic regions
and we also see witches broomings uh one
of the symptoms of glyphosate injury and
this is on apples on the the left
picture
is a shortening of the inter nodes and
when we have the shortening of the
internodes we have a lot of leaves
starting to develop in bunches very
close to each other we don't have that
inner node expansion and we have these
structures that are called witches
brooms developing
the next is the group 15 which is the
long chain fatty acid inhibitors
these are pre-emergent herbicides that
are used to control annual grasses and
some small seed of broadleaf plants
they're not readily translocated we're
not as familiar
with their activity within the cell but
we know that they inhibit very long
chain uh fatty acid biosynthesis
possibly by interfering with elongate
enzyme activities and again these very
long chain fatty acids are components of
cell membranes and they're also
precursors for components of the plant
cuticle
there's uh
chemicals that are part of this class
that you're probably well aware of which
is dual magnum
warren or harness
zidua
again dual magnum pretty common we use
it in a lot of specialty crops here in
new york
injury that's associated with the very
long chain fatty acids inhibitors are
stunting and and leaf distortions often
with the leaves you can tend to see kind
of like a puckering
uh or you know
a crinkling of the leaves
i have seen where sometimes uh these
chemistries get down into the world of
plants if they get applied over the top
of a plant they can get down into the
world into the growing point and then
cause distortions directly to the
growing point
the group nine this is going to be the
cellulose synthesis inhibitors and these
herbicides affect cell wall biosynthesis
in susceptible plants and this inhibits
cell division
so cellulose is a structural
carbohydrate it's used for a protection
and it's used for structure and the
cellulose microfibrils are the
the structures here that are uh
the yellow tubes
and if we can't build uh these cellulose
microfibrils we don't
uh successfully build our cell walls
which means again we're affecting growth
and development if we can't build cell
walls we can't grow we don't have that
that structural
components needed uh for development
so
this is going to have some some uh
chemicals that you you may be familiar
with uh castron if you're working in uh
tree systems
gallery isoxabin we don't have that
registered in new york uh but it is
registered in our surrounding states and
allian a recent active ingredient uh
that has been released into
our and recent relatively
our
uh fruit crop systems uh that we we do
use in
both trees and vines again it's
affecting cell wall development
some of the symptoms that we see
associated with the group 29
is the inhibition of cellular synthesis
are stubby roots and you can see a
picture there it's it's on ground ivy
those stubby roots developing
we do see crinkled leaves uh and
stunting of plants and and plant
structures interestingly enough uh
if you look at the alliant label this is
alli on damage to two grapes um aleon
has a very strict label for for using
grapes with respect to soil type and the
age of the plants um
these are three-year-old grapes on a
very sandy soil in california
and
uh this eleon got used when it was not
supposed to be used and a year later
these grapes were gone uh they had to
they had to be ripped out and this is
the damage that the the alliance did to
this to these fully
seemingly fully grown grapevines uh the
interesting thing is we did this damage
to to the grapes with the alliance i can
tell you that allianz will not touch
field bindweed feel bindweed
also a vine you know you would think
much wimpier
than a great dozen touchfield bindweed
decimated these very young grapes
so why is it important to to know this
information uh just to reiterate what
chiri said
improved efficacy by by having better
knowledge or more knowledge about these
herbicides and how they work
you know it's going to help us improve
our use of them and
improve our weed control performance
it's going to help us understand how
herbicides act within the plants and
then what symptoms they're going to
elicit so we can better diagnose injury
and a lot of it comes down to resistance
management because our best management
practices
for resistance call for diversifying
sites of action
now we get a lot of questions should you
mix or rotate herbicides when we're
talking about diversifying sites of
action so i thought i would throw this
in there
there was a recent study looking at
glyphosate resistant water hemp this
came out of the university of illinois
and what they found is if they were tank
mixing multiple herbicides for
application they were less likely to
have resistance it didn't completely
reduce resistance
but statistically growers were less
likely to have resistance
than if you were rotating your
herbicides applying one and then
switching to a different mode of action
and then switching to a different mode
of action if you were tank mixing you
had the potential for
less resistance but it only works if
each component of the tank mixture is
effective against the target species so
we talked about the specificity of these
herbicides if only one is effective and
the other isn't you haven't
really effectively mixed your products
it's not an end-all solution because i'm
going to tell you australia actually
suggests rotating tank mixtures
for managing herbicide resistant so just
don't mix don't just rotate rotate mixes
where you can
and then of course think about
non-chemical strategies and i do want to
bring this up this this next thing when
we're talking about herbicide resistance
i just talked about
those products that inhibit growth and
development of the plants
all of the arrows and in this
this this this picture right here in
this image right here all of these
herbicides were part of categories that
i just talked about
so the only thing that would have fell
in in the in the category that terry
talked about was atrazine paraquat and
simazine
otherwise we have the accas inhibitors
we have glyphosate we have the als
inhibitors and we have 24d which is a
synthetic auxin so we have a lot of
herbicide resistance particularly to
these herbicides that are associated
with growth and development so i'm just
going to use that to
again
understand
these herbicide sites of action
understand how they're different for
managing resistance because resistance
is our number one problem that we're
facing now
now teary is going to jump to the to the
next
and last topic which is off target
movement so we talked about herbicides
don't always work the way we want them
to well herbicides don't always stay
where we want them to
um
and they can move away from an intended
plant and that is going to have
repercussions for we control for damage
to
desirable crop species and to growers
economic
bottom lines as well as the environment
all right
thanks liam
you you made the introduction for my
talk a little bit easier
so let's
look if i
can put it in presentation mode
and you should see it right now is it is
it okay
thank you um so yeah i mean as as lynn
mentioned i mean the last topic that
leon and i wanted to discuss with you
today was really discussing of target
movement
uh essentially because um
it's a topic you know i i had a great
student working here with me over the
last uh three years working on
off-target movement of uh dicomba on
vegetable crops or on it's a topic for
which in the northeast region it has not
been a premium topic over the last few
years but if you look at what's going on
in the midwest what happened uh the last
two three years in the midwest with
daikon back crop
i think it's really important to really
understand what's going on with
off-target movement what are some of the
concepts that we are discussing on how
to prevent it uh as well because we we
are not immune to to this kind of
problem
in the narcissist region
uh so we'll be discussing ebised
retention in zombie month we'll be
looking at how herbicide is is
over time so it can be through the
gravitational movement
we'll focus on episode of target
movement on on we'll be finally
discussing preventing of target movement
as well
so when you apply the heavy side there
is only a minimal fraction of this
herbicide that will really be effective
on the weights actually in most
situations most of the herbicide
is uh reaching the soil or reaching uh
you know staying in that atmosphere for
a little bit of time or things like that
but only a small fraction is actually
really directed targeting uh the the
weed that you want to control
so there is many things happening it can
be taken up by the plant uh with
different type of herbicide you can have
volatilization means that the herbicide
is vaporizing uh getting from a liquid
formulation to a to a gas
you can have photochemical decomposition
with some chemical family of herbicide
you can have runoff on erosion with most
of them you can have chemical breakdown
depending on soil condition especially
for treasing herbicide
most herbicides will be
degraded at some point by microbes by
soil soil microorganism
sorry
you can also have leeching
of the herbicide
deeper into the ground or in some
situation unfortunately reaching the
water table
are on the last thing is really the
interaction interaction between the soil
on the heavy side so that's what we'll
be discussing right now
so here besides our retention there's
two concepts that really are important
to understand on what is driving these
concepts one is absorption i didn't say
absorption i said absorption which is
really
the retention of herbicide compounds
onto the soil particle through chemical
interaction so through chemical bonding
so an absorption of this herbicide on
this uh sole particle will determine
how long herbicide will persist in the
environment and potentially be available
for being taken up by by crops over time
uh so you have absorption but at the
same time you may have another process
which is disruption which is basically
the reversal of absorption you may have
herbicides that can be absorbed for some
period of time on salt particle
on if a soil condition are changing
these herbicide
will move back into solution into into
the water solution into the soil and at
this time may be available for taken up
by crops and that's explained what you
know that's one of the concepts which is
explaining carryover you
you have heard herbicide that is
absorbed to solve particular or not
sometime in the season you may have more
rain the herbicide will be back into the
soil solution into water in the soil and
be taken up by by the following crops
so the retention will depend on
different soil parameters uh of course
salt texture um clay soil have more
capacity for adsorbing herbicides and
sandy soil that will depend on organic
matter content the higher the organic
matter content the more capacity for the
herbicide to be absorbed by the soil
depending on the cationic change
capacity depending on the ph because the
ph will change the
binding capacity of each herbicide by
polarizing the episode molecule and it
will also depend on water holding
capacity
it will depend on herbicide chemical
characteristic i mentioned variety but
yes some herbicide may be more prone to
soil absorption than some of the
herbicide it will depend on microbial
the higher the microbial activity the
faster the hemiside will be degraded in
the soil and of course it will depend on
the mental conditions so
water immediate temperature are all
factors that will play a role in
absorption or disruption of the
herbicide in the soil
so herbicide degradation
is that's a different set of
degradation process but we can have
photochemical degradation so some
herbicide can be
really quickly uh
be
breaking down under uv light so
that's the case with some dynamic
herbicide
you know that i mean for example
triferaline
which is in dinotronin herbicide
need to be uh
buried into the solar relatively quickly
after after application
mostly because there is there is a risk
of photodegradation of the herbicide
molecule and when the herbicide molecule
is photodegraded basically you're
getting another compound which is may
not be an herbicide anymore
um you that will the degradation speed
of degradation will depend also on
microbial activity it will depend on uh
chemistry of the soil so it will depend
on the capacity of the salt to hydrolyze
or create a redux reaction with these
molecules on on changing
the conformation or the type of
herbicide molecule
on it will depend also on metabolisms
with somewhere beside i mean the plants
on herbicide are not suffering from
herbicide injury
mostly because they have this metabolic
capacity for breaking down the molecule
of the episode very curatively rapidly
so herbicide of target movement that's
another fate of herbicide once you
applied it so that's really when the
herbicide is moving from
the internet plant or site where you
want herbicide to be
so that's usually
some of the consequences of herbicide
moving off target
is really that you're reducing your
weight control
because you don't have enough product
where it was supposed to be uh you may
have a lot of unwanted damage to
neighboring vegetation it's a waste of
money on time uh it it creates some
environmental concern as well as some
illegal pesticide residues you may have
herbicide drifting to a neighboring crop
on which herbicide is not labeled on if
you are harvesting the product you may
detect
residues of the herbicide even if you
did not apply it if you never applied an
herbicide of drifter to your field you
may end up with residue of herbicide
that is not specifically able for this
crop
ultimately yes it can have huge legal
and financial reparations so that's
that's really a big concern um that we
have with uh of target movement of every
side so we'll mostly focus on three
different type of target movement today
we'll focus on on carryover we'll focus
on vapor drift uh which is chemical
rotation we'll focus on particle drift
which is really the movement of
herbicide spray
into the atmosphere but we have also uh
other type of target movement
you may have a movement of soil that has
been contaminated with herbicide to
another location and that can create
problems you can have leaching of the
herbicide deeper in the soil you can
have misapplication you can have stone
contamination that can create off-target
movement as well
so herbicide cure over we'll start with
this one so that's really the capacity
of an herbicide to persist into the soil
on coast potential damage to the fallen
crop so the potential for herbicide to
carry over and cause injury to the
following crops will depend on two
factors essentially
one is the concentration of the
available herbicide remaining in the
soil at the time of fresh rotational
crop planting so again that will depend
on herbicide characteristics soil
characteristics on environmental
characteristics
essentially the weather
on the second parameter that you have to
take into account is that a different
rotational crop may have different
susceptibility to a specific herbicide
so i will show you a picture actually
this one right here this picture is
showing reflex herbicide i mentioned
that before in my previous talk for
mesophane
we know for example that cabbage are
extremely sensitive to reflex carryover
as demonstrated in this picture i mean
you applied reflex uh 200 days before
transplanting this cabbage on you still
have i mean you have a huge loss of
cabbage right here on these plots
if you are planting a different crops if
you are planting a maybe pumpkin or
squash i think the
the rotational interval is just hormones
so if you have plant a different uh crop
you will not see this kind of injury so
it's really uh crop crop specific but
basically when you're looking at the
herbicide care river
if you have high clay or organic organic
matter content
that will cause more herbicide binding
to salt particles and actually because
you have more soil uh
salt binding of this herbicide uh you
will have less activity for microbial
degradation so microbial microbial
degradation may be slow down maybe slow
because you have this herbicide attached
to the soil particle
on basically since at some point in time
they can be uh
getting back into the soil into the
water in the soil as that's a potential
concern uh soil ph will affect herbicide
chemical and microbial degradation uh so
microbiota the microbial degradations
tend to be
more active around ph seven when we have
neutral soil um so if you have solid
very acidic soil like what we have here
in the pine barrels uh we know that we
don't have a lot of
a lot of microbial degradation of the
episode and that may be a concern with
some residual herbicide that we are
applying to this sunday soil
and something important to keep in mind
too and let me explain why we have
sometimes damaged in spring with
carryover is that when you have cold
soil early spring the soil is relatively
cold cold soil will decrease microbial
activity and that will slow down the
process of degrading the herbicide and
when you have cold soil in spring that's
maybe sometimes the perfect condition
for really getting some kind of injury
early season
um so the other point two is that uh one
on most condition will increase
microbial activity and herbicide
degradation but what is really important
right here is that warm on moist
if you have uh a drought if you have
really uh uh you know if you don't have
enough water in the soil that will slow
down the activity of these microbes they
will slow down the degradation of this
herbicide and that's what you see on the
curve
on the right of this slide
clearly i mean if you have a wetsuit you
can get in some situation you can get
herbicide degradation
up to the level which is stay safe for
rotating to the to the next drop you can
get that in 20 weeks if you have a dry
year it will take three times more to
reach this threshold where you can have
uh
a level of herbicide low enough for
planting the foreign crop so that's
something important to consider uh and
it's really something i mean if you're
looking at what's going on these days um
you know lynn and i were looking at um
you know
a message that was posted recently uh
regarding illinois regarding the midwest
they got some drought issue last year
really dry year on release are concerned
that this year because of what happened
in 2021 because it was a dry tier a dry
year in 2021 they are concerned that
they may start to see some herbicide
injury
an increase in herbicide injury from
carryover because of of condition that
that we had last year
so what are some of the strategies that
you can adopt for reducing the risk of
every side carryover well the first
thing is really i mean i mentioned my
previous talk but really look at the
product label follow these
recommendations that are attached to the
label regarding the rotational
restriction plan back interval
make sure that yes you're following that
because it's it's really important
ensure that ceiling stress are minimized
usually carryover is
if um
carryover issue are more important on
young seedlings and established ceilings
so everything that you can have at the
time of establishment of crop
establishment for reducing stress
fertilization moisture
fungicide this kind of thing that will
reduce stress on the seedlings
will also allow
seedlings to survive calories better and
to have eventually better metabolic
activity
uh if needed you can change your plant
pro the product that you're planning uh
if if you're not sure about potential
caregiver injury you can delay the
planting there is discussion that
teenage may eventually be improving but
i didn't see any strong evidence that
may be the case as the last thing that
uh sometimes we don't do enough is
really try to do a kind of small bio
essay you know homemade bioisa take soil
from from the field where you want to
plant your crop plant something which is
relatively sensitive to herbicide in
that case in this picture it was alfalfa
on look at you know compared to a piece
of salt that has not been treated only
look at both after just a few days
looking at how many
seedlings have emerged in comparing a
soil that has been treated with air
besides a producer on a soil that has
not been treated uh coming from from you
know from from the same area and that
can be a good indicator of what is the
potential for carryover damage
um the other thing that i wanted to
discuss is really heavyside drift which
is a movement of herbicide droplets or
dust as i showed you in the previous
presentation
through air at the time of application
or soon after application to any other
site than the internet area
um on this two different type of uh
heavyside drift there is one we are
creating vapor drift which is a movement
of an herbicide as a gas or a vapor
during or immediately after application
and that's the result of volatilization
of the herbicide on the second one is
particle drip it's basically these
tiny droplets that are making your
stress solution are moving away from
where you want them to be they're moving
away and they're traveling uh
you know
into the air
um so vapor drift the first one it will
mostly depend on air vapor pressure
which is really a chemical
characteristic of each episode and it
will depend on formulation of the
herbicide
on for example some herbicides that are
really well known for for vapor drift
240 dicomba chromosomes are everything
that are really well known for for for
volatilizing relatively quickly uh if
you're looking at formulation if you're
i mean on the higher the higher the
vapor pressure the higher the risk of
monetization
so if you're looking for example a 240
formulation if you're looking at an
amine or acid formulation
you will have a lower vapor drift with
this kind of formulation than if you are
using an ester formulation of two
phobias so actually yes i mean we know
that herbicide such as 240 can drift
volatilize relatively easily but the
formulation is really something that can
mitigate this volatilation and actually
these days for specialty crop we are we
are getting some formulation like 240
choline that's a new truffle formulation
by coptiva which tends to be really low
uh volatility and that can eventually
reduce the risk of potential of target
movement
particle drift and that's that's nice
visual where you can really see that
with the wind you can see the the cloud
of of
tiny droplets moving away uh from from
the sprayer uh swash uh so that that's
not visual right here but really the
spread rocket size is really one
fundamental parameter that that is
explaining
um uh particle drift so the smaller the
droplets the greater chance that this
droplet will drift toward to a greater
distance
um so usually droplet size is measured
in micrometers which is 125 thousand of
an inch really small
to give you a comparison a pencil lead
is around 2000 micrometers when a human
air is around 100 micrometers and that's
the size of some of the droplets that
you're spraying
so the nozzle usually when you're
applying your herbicide with a sprayer
the nozzle will produce a range of
different droplet size you will not just
have a single droplet size you will have
an
you know depending on the nozzle you
will have a range of droplet size and
usually
that is described by the volume medium
diameter of the droplet which is the
median droplet size of a volume of spray
from the nozzle so basically if you have
in the nozzle you can spray from 50 to
200 micrometers
but
half of the nozzle will be below 100
micrometers on the other half would be
above 100 micrometers so that will be
the volume medium diameter that we are
talking here
so if you're looking at this graph
basically yes the biggest droplets uh
the bigger the micrometers
the least they will travel over time
actually if you're looking at the 200
micrometers it's it's not drifting far
away if you're looking at the 150
micrometers that's the one which is
drifting further away um
on this one um you know it's drifting at
some point in the atmosphere on
depending on atmospheric characteristics
especially humidity these droplets may
start disappearing by by vaporizing but
you're moving from a spray drift to a
vapor drill basically but basically yes
these droplets as physical droplets can
move over big distance if you start
getting smaller droplets
they may stay in the atmosphere
relatively long but they can vaporize
relatively quickly as well
so wind speed is something to consider
as well so when you have
a two times increase in wind speed
that will result in 700 percent increase
in drift uh
90 feet don't wind up the sprayer so a
really wind speed is something to
consider because that can significantly
increase the risk of target movement
um usually we tend to consider that
ideal wind speed for spring herbicide is
between three and ten miles per hour
i didn't say zero i already put three to
ten
and i will explain why why we
you know why zero is not a good idea
that's why we don't i mean zero is dead
calm on we don't want to spread during
uh dead can conditions and the reason is
that when you have dead can condition
that may be because you have temperature
on temperature inversion it occurs when
a warm light air rise upward into the
atmosphere and you have easy cool uh air
that will settle
near the ground i'm probably seeing the
mixing of air layers so usually it's the
reverse you know it's it's really the
the warm air close the ground we start
moving upward on
the
the cold air is located above um ions
altitude now when you have temperature
inversion actually the cool air is
really located uh close to the ground
and the warm air is higher in the in
altitude
uh so when you have this kind of
temperature inversion basically the
small droplets will remain suspended in
air and they will move to great distance
laterally horizontally for as long as
the inversion is lasting
so usually tamper transaction will begin
to set to set up around the time of
sunset um so if you have no clouds or
wind
to mix the air that's perfect condition
for for uh for for getting a temperature
in version
um
so that's a nice
picture where you can really see that
issue i mean the top picture you have
vertical mixing of the hair so you can
see that the smoke is mixing rising in
the air
when you see the bottom picture where
you have a more where the smoke is is is
really staying as a layer across the
ground that's condition in which we have
temperature inversion
so also cold air drainage can influence
movement of very small herbicide
droplets
so especially because cool air can drain
into lower areas during the night
so because cool air is denser it will
move to areas
with at lower elevation or on that can
be a condition that will create a
temperature inversion as well
so some indicators of temperature
inversion
when you have clear night on nacla no
clouds that's perfect condition for
temperature inversion a wind below three
miles per hour you may have temperature
innovation if you see dew or frost
that's condition
during which you may have a temperature
inversion
horizontal smoke patterns a groom fog in
low lying areas
are indicative of temperature inversion
on the last one and actually i i learned
about this when i was preparing that
when i was preparing the presentation
when you can hear distant sounds that
then when you can hear them really well
that may be indicative of some patching
version as well so look at this
condition
because otherwise you really don't have
any way to know the temperature
inversion you will not measure the
temperature
60 feet above the crop you will not do
that so look at this kind of
visual indication that are a condition
during which you don't want to apply an
herbicide
so relative humidity and temperature are
also important to consider regarding
you know drift
a physical drift so if you have low
relative humidity and high temperature
basically the heavy side i mean the
droplets will be reduced inside because
you will have some water evaporation
on the more they're beside the more the
droplet is reduced in size the further
it can travel with the wind if you have
higher relative humidity low temperature
you don't have so much evaporation uh
from from from the from the spread
droplets on the droplets will not travel
on a longer distance
spray pressure is also important to
consider
so the higher the pressure the smaller
the droplets
um so if you have if you know the
relationship between the two between
pressure and flow rate it's not a linear
it's not a linear relationship actually
if you're multiplying the pressure by
four you will have
you will have an increase by by two
times of the flow rate
on increasing that you know we will
reduce the droplet size as well
so selecting the proper nozzle is is
also important uh to consider
uh if you know if you have um
it will depend on the type of herbicide
that you're spraying if you're spraying
systemic herbicide that can move into
the plants from
the area where they're reaching the
plant to a different area into the plant
you can consider getting coarse droplets
because the episode will be there it
will move then when it's absorbed by the
plant it can move into the pump now if
you're looking at contact herbicide like
bromoxon you need to maximize the
surface of the weeds that we receive
herbicide because these heavy sides are
not moving into the plant so in this
condition you may be using a medium
medium-sized
nozzle for this type of herbicide
so either pesticide contact or systemic
we just discuss that
so
if if you have drift concern as well so
if you're looking at the labels some
label will specifically indicate that
you need to use some specific um
nozzle because there is potential drift
constant with this type of herbicide so
looking at the label is always a good
idea oops yeah here we go so if you're
looking at selecting the proper nozzle
some nozzles are always color coded
red nozzle correspond to the very fine
straight droplets are on usually with
herbicide we really recommend using
as much as possible either white green
or blue
eventually yellow
but in in in my program i'm discussing
with rovers we really tried to set
grower do not use red or orange because
it's it's a recipe for targeting some of
target movement
uh so selecting the i mean i mentioned
it before but selecting the proper
nozzle will depend on the type of
episode so if you have contact for your
herbicide
medium sized
nozzle
will be better
uh if you have soil applied herbicide
you can use coarser very coarse uh
nozzle for for this type of heavy size
boom height is also important to
consider so the higher the boom the
greater the drift potential
uh a two times increase in height will
result in three fifty percent increase
in drift 95 downwind of the sprayer so
that's that's something keep the boom as
close as possible from the crop to
reduce potential of target movement
if you're looking at the t-jet catalog
actually really they are providing you
with indication on what is the optimal
height that you need to follow
when depending on the type of nozzle
that you're using so it's relatively
easy i would say for most of the nozzles
we try to keep it between 16 and 18
inches above the crop
but that will depend on for some other
nozzle you can go up to 20 24 inches
follow the label again i mean i put a
picture of of callisto label but
you have restriction on the label so
make sure that you're reading the label
carefully because that can provide you
information regarding the type of nozzle
that you need to use
or regarding a condition that
during which you can apply the herbicide
for so for example for kalisto to
clearly say the clearly said that you
cannot apply this herbicide when the
wind speed
is exceeding 10 miles per hour only you
can not apply it during temperature and
version as well
um
so other tips other you know tricks is
sometimes you can use sprayer especially
in vegetable crops when we're using
post-emergent service side
i know that we try to do our best to use
sugar sprayer because you can get
off-target movement with any kind of
herbicide and since veggies vegetable
crops are extremely sensitive to every
size uh injury from from drift we try to
use uh shooter sprayer for that
uh use lower low volatility formulation
of 240 or dicamba if you have to use
this herbicide
do not forget to eventually add drift
reducing adjuvants to increase the
number of large droplets when possible
lower the boom height we discuss that
maintain buffers to sensitive crops
that's something important uh to look to
on the label as well is that the label
may have indication that you need to
maintain a certain distance from when
you're spraying from from a neighboring
crop that may be sensitive to this
herbicide so pay attention to this
buffer zone
uh don't spray during high humidity i
know i mean high humidity maybe
you know causing off-target movement
some herbicide you really don't have the
choice because i was mentioning blue
fuzziness before
i mean we prefer to spray uh refrigerate
when we have high humidity but you need
to be extremely careful when you do that
it's not drifting to neighboring crops
uh if if humidity if you're adding the
humidity the percentage of humidity on
the air temperature
if you're reaching 125 uh you do not
spray spray when you know it's it's a
rule of thumb but spray when the
condition when humidity on air
temperature when you're adding both
together are
less than 125
monitor wind on other environmental
factors
properly clean the sprayer when when
you're done because one
uh other way of getting off target
movement is really is ready to get done
contamination i didn't discuss it but
really making sure especially with 240
or dicomba airy side that are really uh
acting at low concentration
make sure you really do a a proper
cleaning of your straight tongue
because it can you don't need a lot with
these hairy sides i mean lean on my
convicted studies over the last two
years
depending on the crop you may just need
one five thousand of the labor rate to
see damage on the problem i put a
picture of of dicomba uh injury by on
the
on the on eggplant on on actually this
one was we observed this kind of damage
at up you know at one one thousand of
the level rate we start to see some
injury with dicomba so clean up cleaning
up the tank and making sure that you
don't have herbicide residue in the
tongue is really important especially
with some of these episodes that are
really prone to drift
on with that that will conclude my
presentation on of target movement um i
don't know if we have question or if we
have time for question but i mean if we
have time i will take any questions
thanks terry i know gemma is probably
going to put um
bring up the
the the cca
uh credit
uh
scan the the qr code for cca scans and
uh in the in the chat she has put the
sign out
for the dec
uh i want to thank terry for uh
presenting uh with me today i also want
to thank terry for again all the work
we're doing together uh if you were at
the
snapping session yesterday we we i
actually discussed our dicamba
injury results and how
dicamba injury can induce stress and
snappings which can lead to
uh yield loss
terri and i can stay on for a couple
minutes so if you do have questions uh
you can put them in the chat or
you can ask them if not thank you so
much for attending
and um i will be working with terry to
write up a summary
of our
of the very general information not
necessarily all the details uh for in
inclusion in the the abstracts for the
meeting also if you subscribe to the veg
newsletter terry and i put together
an article that came out a few weeks ago
maybe a month ago on uh the herbicide
shortages we are currently working
on an article about uh drift carryover
volatility tank contamination
uh leaching and runoff impacts hopefully
we'll have that for april for the veg
edge newsletter or some of our other
cornell newsletters as well as uh
rutgers
website
and um
yeah uh terry and i are just gonna be
working together on a lot of uh
extension outreach touches that and
justin uh put in the chat about whether
work has been done on soils or baskets
and the movement of pre-emergent
herbicides and yes soil surfactants are
out there i personally have not worked
with it but i do have
um a soil surfactant that i got from a
company
that we're going to be investigating i
don't know if terry has done work with
soil surfactants i i uh
i did one study last year on it was uh
looking at search surfactants in
cranberry
um
actually i mean they're using salts of
actin not for herbicide but mostly for
some fungicides that are affecting
cranberry roots
and we look at
adding this surfactant which is supposed
to increase fungicide efficacy we added
the surfactant to one of our
pre-emergence application
uh on unfortunately i mean we used it
with sulfantrazone on actually the
the use of the surfactant increase uh
cranberry damage caused by sulfur
transform so that was the case where i
mean i think the episode was maybe not
appropriate because we already know that
so fantastic it's not applied at the
right stage as also post-emergence
activity and can potentially cause
damage but i think that it's an area
where we need to get a little bit more
information
essentially because we we mostly
recommend to use pre-emergence without
reflectance but maybe in some situations
getting a survival made
pre-emergency but
my experience was limited i think yes
it's it's a field to investigate
yeah again my experience is limited i
have talked to companies about it i'm
going to be doing some work to see if we
can use um some soil surfactants to
in sort of safe herbicides by maybe
preventing uh movement outside of
a treated zone and into like our um
where our crop is seeded or to prevent
herbicide movement keeping it in that in
that zone where the weed seeds are most
germinable and and preventing it moving
into where the the root balls of you
know our transplanted crops would be
again um
for for for me it's it's exploratory at
this time we have we have a product in
hand we just
we're going to test it this year uh i
think um christy hope ting is also
hoping to do some tests in in cabbage
for for much the the same reason with
uh an alternate
um
uh soil surfactant
chemical uh but also i i will say i
don't i don't know about teary but uh
alan taylor who's our seed scientist
here uh at cornell agritech in geneva he
and i are also looking at some seed
treatments not necessarily to keep
herbicides from moving but that might be
able to um actually act as a protectant
uh and reduce some of the the injury
potential on some of our seeded crops so
uh i think both terry and i are looking
at you know how can we reduce damage uh
using uh different opportunities whether
they're soil surfactants or seed
treatments you know to to safe in
some of these chemistries in our crops
i'm actually if if you have
that's something that we can disc uh we
can discuss that later but if you have
the contact information for the product
that you may want to test this year
i i may have some interest for cranberry
definitely yeah i will reach out to you
siri um
again if you have questions you can type
it into the chat um
we i know there's 47 participants
hanging on
uh are we able to accept samples to do
residual bio assays uh no we we don't do
that i don't do that i
uh
that's a good question about the labs
though and uh mary cintrella i don't
know she saw in that she maybe she would
know of labs that do
uh testing or you might also reach out
to your local cce specialists who might
know of labs that would be able to do
testing
i'm not going to do bioassay testing but
i am willing to accept your weed seed uh
from from plants that don't die for
resist herbicide resistance screening
actually that's something that i did i
did a few times mostly for
um
you know for making sure that when i was
suspecting uh injury from carryover
uh i took some some sample to from you
know from from a field uh on look at
some sensitive crop and to me i'm using
it uh mostly as a way to confirm what
i've seen in the field
um but i don't know that here in new
jersey we don't i mean the i don't think
there's already a story live i'm quite
sure actually as they do not do that um
you know this it's not the service that
they're proposing so it's mostly
up to the grower to to to do that
you know to evaluate the control over
caregiver
then i'm sorry i missed what you were
talking what kind of testing you were
talking about yeah if you know of labs
that perform soil testing for residual
herbicides uh or bio assays do you know
of any lab yes well
i'm not sure if it's changed since i was
there but i know within entomology
um you know if you talk to scott mcgart
who's a
b researcher
he used to have a lab technician that
would do all sorts of samples and and
you could pay
to get those samples
ran let me i'll look into it for a
second try to put something in the chat
here and see if it's still operating
because i know his technician left but
they might still have someone in that
position
yeah so that that's great again i don't
do it mostly because i'm also trying to
um for our
our greenhouses uh avoid bringing
in uh external soil uh that could have
pests or pathogens uh we'll we'll bring
obviously seed in that you know we've
thoroughly cleaned uh but i do try to
avoid bringing soil into our greenhouses
just from a phyto-sanitary standpoint
um i just put a link in the chat soon
since it looks ted
um
i believe this site works pretty well
you can actually put in the chemical
you're looking to get a sample for
and they might be able to help you out i
don't see a link in the chat dan
it is there now
yeah i was just typing it in so yeah
so again if you've got any questions we
got 30 people on feel free to throw them
in the chat uh let us know again thank
you to our sponsors
uh thank you to gemma for for running
this session behind the scenes
uh thank you uh very much to all of the
cce personnel who are involved in uh
developing the expo and then bringing
the expo from a
in person
to a virtual session uh in very short
notice uh considering the the situation
at the time hopefully we will be back
next year
uh terry and i are already discussing
about possibilities for our future uh
talks which would uh review the
different mechanisms associated with
herbicide resistance the current state
of herbicide resistance and all the
resistance mechanisms from target site
mechanisms to non-target site mechanisms
um
terry and i have also talked about uh
the possibility of in the summer if
we're able to hold
you know a a session here at geneva
agritech of having an hands-on uh
herbicide symptomology uh field day and
field site or at least terry and i have
talked about it and i will just badger
him and further and rope him in to do it
so that people can actually come and see
the injury firsthand
that's going to depend on a lot of
things though
and particularly where covid goes within
the next six months
it's good we already have our talk
scheduled for next year
it's not so common
if you're going to be attending
tomorrow's cover crop talk tiri will be
speaking uh in the cover crop session uh
and if you are a field crops grower and
you've been following jeff miller's uh
he's been sending out a blast about uh
different uh weed science and weed
control related talks on the 15th or the
16th i don't remember which i'm going to
be talking about our non-target
are our non-chemical
uh
speed control technology for resistance
management so we'll be talking about
harvest weed seed destroyers uh we'll be
talking about electric readers uh and
other uh robotic implements the kind of
the future of weed control
so you can register for i believe for
free for that
i just wanted to i did find that link so
i put that in the chat there for the um
the pesticide analysis facility at
cornell it is a little bit expensive for
sample
yeah both both dan and and mary have put
links in there um
that could be valuable for
uh people interested in in in this
all right well if there is no
further discussion i'm gonna close this
down again thank you so much to terry
thank you gemma
um thank you dan and mary for uh
contributions
you're welcome uh
thanks everyone for inviting me to come
today um
great job for moving that from in person
to online it's it's really great
jerry you're a honorary cornell person
now
thanks steve i still know i still have
to come to visit lee in july like
very good we'll see you tomorrow then
see
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu